Stop tampering with the
spell oh my god stop talking
We tampered with the stability of space time
multiverse is a concept about
which we know frighteningly little
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new spider-man no way home video all about the
crossover in connection with doctor strange to
multiverse of madness because that is the next
big marvel movie happening right after the events
of spider-man no way home so obviously they're
connected if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a lot of spider-man stuff coming up it's a good
time to be a spider-man fan but you've all seen
the spider-man no way home trailer a billion times
literally because it broke the avengers endgame
trailer record during the trailer peter goes to
doctor strange one more day style to try and make
people forget that he's spider-man thinking that
that will make things go back to the way they were
before mysterio revealed his identity and because
he's a high school kid classic spider-man style
he doesn't completely think through his actions
and the spell doctor strange uses has way broader
consequences it winds up using a very kang like
or he who remains like method of altering the main
mcu universe timeline the sacred timeline by just
mixing and matching combining aspects of other
timelines where in other realities people did not
learn that spider-man was peter parker but it's a
really simple problem with a really complicated
answer that obviously spider-man doesn't think
through like in the trailer they play that comedic
moment where he's like wait a minute everybody's
gonna forget what about my friends what about the
avengers and even though the trailer footage is
probably a little bit misleading that just leads
to a lot of craziness with the multiverse in the
main mcu reality like they just completely warp
all of reality for a little while until doctor
strange tries to fix everything during the loki
series miss minutes had that tva propaganda video
about the kang multiverse war although at the
time when they first showed it we didn't know
that it was about kang in how nexus events could
lead to another all-out multiverse kang war which
they wind up causing anyway because sylvie kills
he who remains at the end of time thank you very
much sylvie and the true multiverse breaks free
from the sacred timeline all the kang variants
break free in the alternate timelines alternate
universes if you think i'm bad wait till you meet
my variants so during that propaganda video when
miss minutes was talking about the collapse of all
reality and they specifically highlight the word
madness part of that is meant to set up doctor
strange ii multiverse of badness doctor strange
having to contend with the collapse of all reality
even though king the conqueror himself is not
supposed to be the main villain of doctor strange
too and in miss minute's example it was he who
remains kang saying that the kang variants were
going around destroying alternate timelines
alternate universes during the war and in that
example the collapse of all reality was the result
of universes just totally being annihilated he who
remains said that he took goliath he weaponized
him and then just had him go around and eat
just completely consume alternate realities until
only his timeline which he then called the sacred
timeline remained so because kang is not the
main villain of doctor strange too multiverse of
madness even though it's getting even crazier with
the multiverse than spider-man no way home it's
just the next step on the road to the theoretical
collapse of the multiverse because of the rumored
villain of doctor strange 2 the true main villain
i've already done a couple videos about that the
rumored main villain right now is schuma gorith
he's an extra-dimensional being part of a group
called the many angled ones who were born in
the chaos of nothingness that existed before
the multiverse came into existence there was also
some news this week buried in all the spider-man
no way home craziness the scarlet witch would be
a villain for at least part of doctor strange too
like doctor strange versus scarlet witch because
of what she's doing but i think just based on
the way the news was reported and what kevin feige
has said about her character part of that is a bit
of a fake out in the movie they want you to think
that she might be a villain in the film but she's
not really the true villain i'll talk about that
more in a second but how does what doctor strange
and spider-man are doing in spider-man no way
home set up the beginning of doctor strange too
the way they play the footage in the trailer they
want us to think that spider-man does something to
mess up doctor strange's spell and that alters
the main mcu universe in a bad way like you see
new york warping and them getting sucked into
something akin to a black hole of reality here
not too dissimilar from the visual effects that
they used to show you how they were using dark
magic in the first doctor strange movie like if
you came across this footage without understanding
where it came from you might confuse it with
a scene from the first doctor strange movie
but as he's sweeping the spell here you see this
room in the basement turn into what seems like a
way station of the multiverse around this
pedestal which seems like it contains the
box that doctor strange then puts this special
magical energy into like is peter's standing here
freaking out about people forgetting about him
you see the walls blow apart and it seems like
they're inside this nexus space this sort of way
station of the multiverse where they're in between
all these different dimensions i think that's why
they visualize it using that same scene of doctor
strange's tour of the multiverse going through all
these different dimensions from the first doctor
strange movie doctor strange scrambling all of
reality spider-man messing it up just a little
bit so things wind up happening in a bad way so
when doctor strange puts everything back together
one of the consequences is the sinister six
villains like doctor octopus from the tobey
maguire spider-man movies the andrew garfield
spider-man villains wind up showing up in the
main mcu universe and i do think that some of the
trailer footage is a little misleading like they
think that doctor strange understands what's going
on here he's supposed to be the most powerful that
he's ever been according to the person who wrote
doctor strange too so even though he has this very
tony stark iron man type of hubris like i can
accomplish anything i'm the sorcerer supreme
i'm the most powerful sorcerer in the universe
right now even though it seems like they derp
things while the spell is happening he starts
yelling at spider-man stop messing with the spell
he's not in the entire movie he's only in a couple
really big scenes for what you see playing out in
the trailer like we're getting a preview of almost
his entire story arc during the trailer like what
you see in the trailer is pretty much all of him
in the film but all told he's probably only in
the movie for like 15 to 20 minutes tops but as
i said in my previous video it sounds like doctor
strange fixes most of those minor things that pop
up like he manages to put things back together in
a relatively normal way and that has something to
do with a special box that spider-man is trying
to open during the movie but even though it
seems like doctor strange fixes most of the
major problems in the main mcu reality getting
to the doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
of it all what they do has larger ramifications
bigger unseen consequences that they tease in
a spider-man no way home post-credit scene and
those larger problems involve the main villain
of doctor strange 2 taking advantage of all
these warps cracks in the multiverse to break
into the main mcu dimension and that connects
with what scarlet witch was doing with the dark
hold in the wandavision post-credits scene i'm
not expecting a lot of scarlet witch to show up
during spider-man no way home but she is sort of
the thing that connects all this because it's her
messing with the dark hole that sort of sets
a lot of this off too so if she does show up
during spider-man no way home it's probably
not going to be till the post credit scene
but during spider-man no way home the multiverse
problems that they create are mostly about dealing
with these really dangerous spider-man villains
all coming from alternate universes but it's
still very much just dealing with the sinister
six team up during doctor strange two as the
title implies he's dealing with a literal and
metaphorical huge upgrade villain on par with
dormammu coming from an alternate dimension
threatening the collapse of all reality in
a slightly different way from what was happening
in the kang multiverse war during the loki series
that's still going on in the background too but
getting to that news about scarlet witch becoming
kind of a villain for a little while i think based
on what's being reported and the way kevin feige's
talked about her after wandavision they don't want
to completely demonize her character or throw her
under the bus but they're sort of playing on that
idea that she has been a villain at various times
or an antagonist in marvel comics where other
characters have had to deal with her just going
completely off the rails and being super super
op during wandavision agatha harkness said that
inside the dark hold it spoke of her being more
powerful than the sorcerer supreme so scarlet
witch is playing with power and magic she doesn't
fully comprehend yet and she's trying to get her
children billy and tommy back those are the stakes
that they set up in that wandavision post-credits
scene and i think the idea that they wanted to
establish is that she'll just steamroll anyone
who gets in her way including doctor strange who
definitely would not want someone running around
with the darkhold elizabeth olsen said that one of
the reasons why she took off so quickly at the end
of wandavision before the police showed up was
also to avoid having to answer questions about
what she did and i did talk about all the deleted
doctor strange scenes because he was going to show
up and so they wanted to instill this idea that
she wanted to get away so that she could study
from the darkhold without having to answer doctor
strange's questions as well because had he have
shown up there's no way that he would have left
the dark hold with her i'll link some of those
wandavision deleted scenes with doctor strange
down in the description below i've already done a
bunch of videos about those and i've talked about
this in previous doctor strange videos but wanda
uses chaos magic to power her spells schumachoreth
for instance is called the lord of chaos in the
comics and even though he isn't the person who
created the darkhold in the comics it sounds
like marvel is just mixing and matching some
backstories for what's happening in the movies
one of schumagoro's go-to moves is controlling
the minds of other people manipulating them
into helping him enter the main marvel dimension
so people are saying that scarlet witch is going
to be fighting people including doctor strange
during the movie i think the connection is that
she's being manipulated by schumacher who's using
her children to sort of bait her into helping
him enter the main mcu dimension through a couple
different ways or if it's a different main villain
whoever that person winds up being is manipulating
her into thinking that she's saving her children
when really she's just making it easier for
this villain to enter the main mcu dimension
in getting to the multiverse of madness of it all
the collapse of reality in a slightly different
way from the kang multiverse war the threat
in doctor strange 2 is another alioth-like
situation where you have a creature either
destroying or just consuming all of reality
but in doctor strange too it's just a very doctor
strange specific villain it's not eliath or kang
doing all this but while the movie is going on
the kang multiverse war is still playing out in
the background as well so the funny thing is that
you have a number of different multiverse ending
scenarios playing out all at the same time how
apropos that the title of the movie is multiverse
of madness so it's implied though that just like
at the end of spider-man no way home at the end
of doctor strange 2 they also do not completely
fix the multiverse like doctor strange manages to
save the main mcu dimension but the multiverse war
that the kang variants are waging is still going
on that they'll continue to deal with during
loki season 2 and then ant-man 3 quantum mania
so it's this whole idea of escalation like things
get crazy with the multiverse during spider-man
no way home but it's still relatively ground level
then it gets way more cosmic during doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness things get even worse and
then by the time we get to ant-man 3 quantum mania
you finally pay off this true kang multiverse
war and because doctor strange 2 is happening
right after spider-man no way home i do expect
at least a small spider-man cameo during doctor
strange too just a sort of connective tissue
between those two movies they did the exact same
thing with the first doctor strange movie and
then thor ragnarok because those were happening
relatively close together in the timeline so
that might also be one of the spider-man no
way home post credit scenes them showing a scene
that's just directly taken from doctor strange too
also funny connection too between these two movies
although it's more of a coincidence is that sam
raimi directed doctor strange to multiverse
of madness and we have all this tobey maguire
spider-man stuff happening during spider-man no
way home so it's sort of completing this circle
of easter eggs and references just bring it all
back around to those original spider-man movies
i've got a bunch more bonus videos that i'm
working on so leave all your requests in
the comments below the next marvel what if
episode also is the doctor strange episode
that'll be episode four and i'll be posting
that next wednesday just like normal every week
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those everyone click here
for my full spider-man no way home trailer
breakdown and easter eggs and click here to
learn all about the sinister six characters
and what they're doing during spider-man no
way home thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!